whatever you think is eventually going
to happen in the 2024 primary Trump's
lead is exploding in multiple polls this
is the reality of the situation right
now is it early yes can things change
yes is Trump's main opponent a guy who
hasn't even declared a candidacy yet Ron
DeSantis meaning that the numbers may
not really tell us everything we need to
know absolutely but Trump's February
polling bump
simply cannot be denied you know one of
the things I will often say
is we should look at an average of polls
rather than any one poll if you're going
to look at one poll ideally it will be a
highly rated pollster not the CD or
unrated pollsters of no uh good
reputation ideally we would if we look
at one poll it would be a highly rated
pollster but in in a perfect world we
would look at a number of highly rated
polls and take a look at the average
trend lines and say what does this tell
us in general well looking at a bunch of
new polls Donald Trump is expanding his
lead but DeSantis hasn't announced
here's an axios article that summarizes
it four new polls
show Trump has received a boost in
Republican support with one survey
showing him hitting 50 support in a
crowded field
uh could it be the visit to the train
derailment site in East Palestine Ohio
maybe could it be his campaign stops in
South Carolina I don't know but here are
the numbers new Emerson poll has Trump
leading DeSantis by 30 55 to 25 that
used to be a 26 point lead in January
that same poll shows Trump getting a a
four-point bump of 255.25 trump gets 72
percent support among Republicans with a
high school degree or less
that same poll found Trump ahead of
Biden 4642 but DeSantis trailing Biden
other polls new Yahoo news yougov poll
has Trump with an eight-point lead on
DeSantis 47-39 in the last one DeSantis
was ahead so that went from a four-point
DeSantis lead wrong desanctus a DeSantis
lead was four now it's Trump plus eight
that's a 12 point swing in a short
period of time you then have the
Republican polling firm Echelon insights
finds Trump ahead of DeSantis by
1546-31 last month Trump was only up by
two so that's a 13 Point gain for the
failed former president and then in the
first Fox News presidential primary poll
remember Fox News polling is actually
quite good Fox itself doesn't do the
polling a pollster does it but these are
Fox News branded polls they find Trump
ahead of DeSantis by 15
43 to 28. a number of important caveats
here
in general Trump does better when the
polls just say if it's Trump or DeSantis
who do you want when the polls say if
it's Trump or DeSantis or Nikki Haley or
Ted Cruz or Tim Scott or Mike Pompeo or
Mike Pence or uh Sarah Palin the more
people that are included
um the smaller Trump's lead is and
sometimes DeSantis is actually still
ahead in those polls that include
multiple candidates so this is why Trump
knows it's actually better for him for
there to be more candidates if there are
more candidates he does better in the
polling okay now is it possible that
this polling bump for Trump prevents Ron
DeSantis from announcing anything is it
possible Ron DeSantis will look at these
numbers and say wow Trump built a lead
he added four points eight points
sometimes double digits over me over the
last month is this a sign I shouldn't
even get involved
it's hard to say because privately if
you're Ron DeSantis and big Republican
donors are coming to you and saying
listen I've done I've said nothing yet
if you run I will support you and I will
throw a bunch of money behind you if
you're Rhonda Santos and you've got a
bunch of wealthy Republicans who are
telling you that you could reasonably
end up thinking I'm gonna get the money
to catch up fine Trump's leading but
it's March of 2023 the primary isn't
really going to be until June July of 22
May June July April May June July of
2024 I have plenty of time and with a
bunch of this Republican money I could
actually catch up that's a possibility
we have to be honest that this is not
nearly as competitive as some
commentators are making it out to be
it's early and the polls can fluctuate
sure but this is a unique situation
where you have a former president
running in a primary a former president
running in a primary will have fewer
fluctuations than normal so while Ron
DeSantis certainly could grow his
support if he gets into this race my
instinct
is that that support is going to grow
more from picking off ones and twos and
threes from people who have very little
support or even seven like Nikki Haley
in a recent poll than it is from eating
away at Trump support that's my
prediction I'm terrible at predicting
things and you should not make any
Financial bets based on what I'm telling
you but that that's my instinct right
now it cannot be denied that it is not
as close today as many in the media are
making it seem I also have expressed to
you
if DeSantis announces and it becomes a
national campaign
desantis's total lack of Charisma and
seeming commitment to quote take the
high road even though he just comes off
as low energy when he does it I don't
think are going to help him
um so I struggled to see how if it is
Trump versus DeSantis in a long
Republican primary I just don't know how
DeSantis takes it
as many of my viewers and listeners of
course know I have many family members
who work in the field of mental health
and I think one of the most important
things that we can do is to both
increase access and reduce stigma when
it comes to Mental Health Services and
that's why I am thrilled that one of our
sponsors today is better help betterhelp
is the world's largest therapy service
and it is 100 online with better help
you can tap into a network of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
an important word therapists who can
help you with a wide range of issues you
answer a few questions about your needs
and your preferences and better help
will match you with a therapist that
meets your needs you can then talk to
your therapist however you feel
comfortable could be text could be chat
phone video call you can message your
therapist anytime you can schedule live
sessions when it's convenient and if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional church with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but it's on your
schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below